colorado he trains rose and amma eunice
camaros camaro rose
do you love her i love her i love her
too
i love all the usc female fighters
that's why i want my daughter to know
how to know all of that stuff that'd be
cool when she meets a creep like you she
could choke you out
bro i'm going to say something right you
walked up this [ __ ] driver pointing
at me
i came over here during rush hour
and i'm grateful that you're here
nothing but a red line the whole way
over here your girlfriend or wife's you
know they think their friends give you
pressure like what are you going to get
her yeah what are you going to get her
it's like i don't know what is she going
to get me yeah
she's going to get me a flat screen oh
yeah it's ridiculous the pandering you
have to do
no it's like am i in some third world
country i gotta buy off the corrupt
dictator here like
you could have a superpower what would
it be
oh that's a good one
you know what it would be
when i'm when i'm second in line to make
a left
and the person doesn't pull up to get
out in the intersection and make sure i
make it my superpower would be that i
could mentally move them out
into the intersection
and if they gave me the finger i would
slowly slide them into oncoming traffic
i would i wouldn't make them hit
because that's an innocent person over
there
man
you're the first villain i had on my
show everybody on super power is like uh
marvel characters your [ __ ] is like a
villain they're lying to you
everybody's pretending that they care
they don't if you really listen to
people what they care about is what
affects them true nobody gives a [ __ ]
about the eight-year-old who made this
jacket do i do i write him and say thank
you
for sewing this together
no well what did you say about the
military that got people so mad or this
one guy's i was just saying like yeah
the guy who flies the fighter jet okay
and has missile shot and that guy's a
hero however if you're the guy that like
points in the direction that the plane
takes off in
you know what i mean you just had you
have nine different positions since
you've started this sentence yeah
because i've been training training with
trevor whitman oh yeah with my footwork
oh trevor whitman oh my god do you know
him no
the deepest couch in sports
entertainment a lot of people think that
uh they're uncomfortable with my uh my
um elevation are you uncomfortable with
it no i just see all of your
insecurities
a giant desk
while people are talking about eating
fake
jesus [ __ ] christ at some point i was
going to make a point here that's why i
keep looking at here and i just realized
i'm blocking myself out of the camera i
love that you have the jib camera for
this like it's an action movie
let's let's let's swoop in at these two
guys sitting in these unbelievably small
chairs
i literally feel like i'm gonna fall
onto the floor this is insane
you really went all out with the
audience though they got full-sized
adult chairs
are these like from the 20s before they
had like horse tranquilizers in our food
when everybody was like five foot one
i thought you were laughing you were
[ __ ] yawning over here no the
mushrooms are [ __ ] killing me man
i knew it wasn't just weed i was just
like there's no way i'm taking a hit off
of that there's something going on here
mushrooms baby the shrooms i'm shrooming
[Laughter]
he's shrooming and he's wearing pants
like he went riding a horse today
like side saddle or some [ __ ]
really
is that is that you in action or is this
another photoshop
yeah it's a photo shoot people do photo
shoots yeah i know have you ever seen
like a movie poster and you'll see a
movie star he's clearly
five foot two yet somehow he's as tall
as the super have i have yeah that's
that's a photo shoot no fix stuff
look i'm sorry you're just on the web
man
you you took it this he took it to this
place i'm not trying to [ __ ] on his
website what is it called again
huh zippitydoodah.com so are you in the
i cannot get comfortable in this [ __ ]
chair this is just like one of the worst
things
this should be like at a museum is like
the prototype this is what
this was the awful level of comfort we
went from a log to this and then
eventually they got cushions
there's another guy looking at his phone
i swear to god
through the day jesus comes back if he
ever does if he's even a real person
like 90 of people are gonna miss it
they're gonna walk right he's gonna be
walking on water and immediately walking
by him they're not even gonna see it
a lot coming from the hillary clinton
camp that trump is bad for children and
they had a lot of ads that said you know
children are watching this guy oh we all
know that children five and six years
old they're always tuning into the
debates
taking notes that's what i did when i
was a kid i'll never forget that
my favorite position is
uh doggy style
you're so nasty i know i can't i just
can't deal with the intimacy you know
i don't know who i am as a person yet
and when somebody looks at me
during that time i just i feel like it's
i'm exposing too much
i was talking about
your position on the basketball court
oh there we go no but now this is like
the ego one now i'm gonna be sitting
above you you gotta come with two
it's fine that's what sir the one the
one comedy through line that's working
here is me [ __ ] on this chair why
would you take that from me
this is you're just totally going
against the grain
i understand it but you got on camera so
i think you get paid even though this is
online
and then also you can't you can't
tell other people's kids not to do stuff
right so you got to kind of like be
loudly like hey he's climbing up on the
utility pole and kind of hope that
somebody does something
well back in the day you could yell at
people's kids and i think that that
needs to come back and that's what's
holding back this country yeah
other people really are the whitest
person i've ever seen around yes
served me well i've never worked for
anything
yeah i was born on a yacht
it's just all been downhill i don't even
mean it and i don't mean it in in a a
genetic way i mean like i do you i'm
talking full-on white privilege
[Laughter]
i was stunned when i first heard about
white privilege i had no idea what it
was it's like everybody doesn't get to
do this
it seems as if the cell phone
job interviews right as i get out of the
car you're higher
i have this uh mic on so yeah that's all
right be a gentleman and help me out
with my point
hey
cody can you believe that marriage
didn't work out
gee i can't believe your relationships
don't work out
[Music]
being a mother is the hardest job most
difficult job oprah said that oprah said
that yeah has that has your opinion on
that on that phrase changed at all since
no
[Laughter]
it's not the most difficult job on the
planet
it just isn't
dude i did roofing in july i almost as a
redhead i almost died
there's people
there's people that work on like oil
what was that movie that guy made the
oil the [ __ ] you know they grow oil
what is it there will be blood there
will be blood the uh out in the ocean
they would drill i could never remember
their names
mark wahlberg
horizon yeah yeah those guys were
working on on an oil rig the [ __ ]
thing blows up
they're on fire they gotta jump into
water that's on fire
salty water into their wounds you gotta
swim out of that oil and fire and then
tread water
praying to god that the coast guard is
going to get there before the sharks do
now talk to me about a toddler oh he was
so fussy today i just
he wouldn't eat his peas
yeah and just the level of reward that
is you know as annoying as a kid is like
they smile at you and it's over it's
over so i mean you don't get that you
know working on an oil rig when your
buddy's greasy face lights up
you're like you know what it really is
all worth it
so your christian background is is part
of the the show yes and i wanted to talk
to you about jesus after that well
not the only reason why i bring it up
but some people thought maybe you went a
little too far you know as far as what
well they thought that maybe you were
being disrespectful to the christian
religion
i'm telling you you need to google
oh good lord so did you feel you were
disrespectful or just you you were just
having fun with some of the crucifixes
and stuff like that
i don't even know what yeah i mean we
did maybe two jokes about that yeah
exactly don't you think the catholic
church went a little too far
more so than my cartoon all right listen
a couple of jokes i know this is a
morning show you can't bring up all
those crimes you know what they just
they just sort of kept moving them
around you know like those killer whales
at sea world after it kills a trainer
they'll then move it up to seattle they
don't give them their background
all right i'm not totally following
but i don't think you know what i'm
talking about it's a morning show i
understand
the game
that kid was missed the graduation and
then it was a feel-good story
and we want to leave if you want to feel
good about america you watch the morning
shows you don't watch this you know and
one i was joking earlier if that kid's
story about the graduation was late
night that would have been a whole
different story what do you think he's
still missing we can't find him all we
found was his hat but you watch in the
morning it's great it all worked out he
got his own personal graduation like i
was in such a great mood look how yellow
this couch is it's like the sun